los miembros de un comité estaban
eligiendo un presidente y cada miembro
dio su voto a favor de uno de los 27
candidatos para cada candidato el
porcentaje exacto de votos que obtuvo
fue menor por al menos 1 que el número
de votos para dicho candidato que esto
esto estuvo muy extraño vamos a leer
nuevamente esto dice los miembros de un
comité estaban eligiendo un presidente
cada miembro dio su voto a favor de uno
de los 27 candidatos ok eso es una
información importante hay 27 candidatos
ahora para cada candidato el porcentaje
exacto el porcentaje exacto de votos que
obtuvo fue menor por al menos 1 que el
número de votos para dicho candidato la
pregunta es cuál es el mínimo número de
miembros para dicho comité así que para
poder resolver este problema vamos vamos
a definir algunas variables que nos
permitan visualizar
con aritmética álgebra y cómo resolver
este problema no va a permitirnos ver
restricciones que tenemos para el total
de miembros entonces digamos que m es el
número de miembros del comité número de
miembros ok entonces y también vamos a
definir otra variable necesitamos el
número de votos verdad fue aquí estamos
hablando del porcentaje de votos que
obtuvo fue menor que la blabla al menos
1 que el número de votos entonces
digamos que se y es el número de votos
número de votos de para el candidato
candidato y ok estamos pensando entonces
que y va es 1 2 3 y así sucesivamente
hasta el 27 verdad tenemos 27 candidatos
entonces qué es lo que nos dice el
porcentaje exacto de votos cuánto cuál
es el porcentaje de votos bueno tenemos
que es la proporción verdad tenemos 6
entre m
/ m esto nos da un número entre entre 0
y 1 verdad y si yo lo quiero en términos
de porcentaje yo necesito multiplicar
por 100 entonces este es el porcentaje
de votos que obtuvo el candidato i y nos
dice que tiene que ser menor o igual que
por al menos 1 que el número de votos
entonces no es es menor o igual que el
número de votos pero además nos dice que
al menos 1 entonces si le restamos 1
sigue siendo menor o igual entonces esta
expresión de aquí
hasta que acabo de escribir es
exactamente lo que dice este enunciado
que subraya con azul solo que de hecho
esta es la parte más difícil del
problema escribir este enunciado que es
bastante truculento que es bastante
engañoso y que realmente está yo creo
pensado para distraernos y que tengamos
confusión de cómo plantear el problema
por una vez que está planteado va a ser
muy sencillo ahora queremos nosotros
minimizar el número de candidatos perdón
el número de miembros del comité
queremos minimizar el número de miembros
del comité entonces si nosotros
minimizamos el número de votos que se
otorgaron a cada candidato ahí nos da un
buen y un buen número para minimizar el
número de miembros verdad porque el
número de miembros será igual a la suma
de todos los votos si sumamos todos los
votos nos da todos los miembros del
comité entonces vamos a minimizar el
número de votos de cada candidato qué es
lo que vamos a hacer
vamos a escribir el mínimo mínimo número
número de votos de votos por candidato
por candidato muy bien
muy bien entonces sí sí vamos a ir
jugando con con los posibles números que
tenemos aquí por ejemplo qué tal si no
le hubiéramos dado votos a ningún
candidato estoy inmediatamente te debe
sonar raro pero lo que puedes ver es que
al menos la diferencia es de 1 entonces
de menos tuvo que haber un voto para
cada candidato entonces este no es
posible puede ser que le hayamos dado un
voto a cada candidato
pero entonces regresemos a esta
expresión de aquí
qué pasa si para algún candidato le
dimos un voto entonces tendríamos que
aquí esto vale 1 - 1 que esto es 0
verdad
esto valdría 0 esto de aquí y si esto
vale 0 aquí me está dando un porcentaje
que es que es un número mayor que 0
entonces resulta que el porcentaje fue
menor o igual que 0 le tendría que
quedar que el porcentaje fue igual a 0 y
eso no es posible verdad
el porcentaje es un número positivo
entonces este de aquí tampoco puede ser
vamos a ver podría ocurrir
podría ocurrir que a lo mejor tengamos
dos votos mínimo por candidato entonces
para visualizar mejor esto vamos a
escribir esta fórmula distinto digamos
esto esencialmente es 6% / m
podemos sacar el recíproco o el inverso
multiplicativo y nos queda m entre 100 y
y aquí como sacamos el inverso tenemos
que cambiar la desigualdad hacia mayor o
igual y esto va a ser mayor o igual que
el inverso del lado derecho que es 1
entre 1 entre
y menos un ok entonces si ahora
multiplicamos de ambos lados por 100 se
nos queda que m es mayor o igual que
ciencia
/ / 6 -1 muy bien entonces qué es lo que
tenemos si nosotros tenemos que hay 2
votos por candidato el mínimo digamos
que el mínimo es 2 votos entonces
tenemos que si sustituimos aquí tenemos
100 por 2 son 200 entre 2 - 1 eso nos da
que el número de miembros es mayor o
igual que 200 muy bien tenemos al menos
200 miembros ok vamos a ver qué pasa si
nosotros tenemos tres que tenemos tres
que sea el mínimo número de votos
entonces
si lo sustituimos acá tendremos 3 por
100 son 300 entre 3 menos uno que son 2
300 entre 2 son 150 entonces tenemos m
va a ser mayor o igual que 150 vamos a
ver entonces fíjate que a medida que
aumentamos el número de él el mínimo
número de votos también disminuimos
el número el número de elementos es
decir m va a ser mayor o igual que 150
entonces a lo mejor 150 es nuestra
propuesta vamos a ver qué pasa cuando
tenemos 4 entonces 100 por 4 son 400
entre 4 menos 1 son 3 400 entre 3 son
133 con un tercio ok pero además m es un
número entero y no puede ser 133
entonces al menos tienen que ser 134 muy
bien vámonos por ejemplo ahora qué pasa
si tenemos
que el número mínimo de votos por
candidatos 5 entonces tenemos 100 por 5
son 500 500 entre 5 menos 1 que son 4
son 125 entonces m es mayor o igual que
125 entonces a lo mejor 125 es nuestra
propuesta sin embargo hay que considerar
algo este también tenemos que considerar
lo siguiente perdón tenemos que
considerar lo siguiente hay que
considerar que al menos también tenemos
si el número de votos por candidato es
por ejemplo 2 entonces tenemos 27
candidatos y por lo tanto de miembros
hay 27 por 2 verdad si multiplicamos
cualquiera de estos números por el
número de candidatos también nos da una
restricción para el número de miembros
por ejemplo si tenemos 2 tenemos vamos a
escribirlo el número mínimo
el mínimo número de votos
el mínimo número de votos y eso es una
cota inferior o al menos un número
mínimo para él para los miembros verdad
entonces si tenemos dos votos por
candidato al menos al menos vamos a
tener 54 votos si tenemos 33 por 27 van
a ser tres por 7 21 y llevamos 22 por 3
son 6 y 2 son 8 tenemos 81 sí tenemos 44
por 27 es 4 por 7
de 7 x 4 son 28 y llevamos 22 por 4 son
8 y llevamos 2 son 10 108 y si tenemos
55 por 27 son 135 muy bien entonces
fíjate muy bien que aunque si tenemos 5
votos al menos también es cierto que al
menos tenemos 135 entonces tenemos que
al menos son 125 y al menos son 135
entonces el número de miembros debe ser
al menos 135 pero aquí teníamos una cota
mejor verdad 134 bueno aquí sí si el
número de miembros debe ser más grande
que 134 y más grande que 108 pues esta
es la que le gana verdad es realmente la
que hay que considerar entonces el
número de miembros debe ser 134 al menos
porque aquí ya nos dice que debe ser al
menos 135 ésta es una mejor es un mínimo
mejor verdad este 134 se puede alcanzar
por ejemplo si tenemos 26 personas con 5
si una persona con cuatro votos verdad o
bien podríamos tener 26 personas con 4
votos y una persona con 30 votos
entonces esta sí se puede alcanzar de
alguna forma cumple todo lo que hemos
planteado y es el mínimo número posible